so to secret the personal technology has
woven itself deep in the fabric of our
everyday lives we're here at CES January
2010 and sandwich between the asus
computer booth and the US Postal Service
is the ed hardy booth now it's a
high-end fashion line which you may have
heard of it's known for loud tattoo
style prints and obviously the jewel
cases so what we've got here my lovely
assistant is holding a motorola droid
piece and an iphone case now these cases
run between ten to fifty dollars but
there's a high-end line that runs a
thousand dollars and up because it's
covered in Swarovski crystals if you
don't want to carry around a cell phone
that's bedazzled but you have a laptop
or a netbook we've also got a pretty
amazing jewel-encrusted laptop so I'm
never gonna have to take this one home
and I'm pretty sure I'm gonna be taking
this one
you